Rules for Trading in Stocks.
Stock trading means buying and selling stocks on the stock market.
Investment and returns are the basic terms,...
...and the basic principle is to buy low and sell high.
Before you begin trading,...
...you should be aware of the benefits and drawbacks,...
...as well as the two types of stock trading.
Advantages are that you can have an immediate profit...
...and you can trade anywhere in the world through the Internet.
A disadvantage is that the profits are lower than with the share market.
In order to trade, there is also a fixed cost,...
...a specific amount of money you must have.
The two types of stock trading are daytime trading...
...and short-term trading or swing trading.
These really depend on the amount of time you have available.
If you have plenty of time during the day,...
...then you should choose daytime trading.
If you don't have time and still want to trade,...
...you should opt for short-term trading.
Online stock trading has lower commission rates and is much simpler than other forms.